wie wird es denn jetzt weiter gehen also
zwei monate ist klar bauen dann
gastronomiebetriebe dann um vom
nachtlokals zum restaurants du hast ja
auch zu recht gesagt die restaurants
sind weiterhin geöffnet was wird da
jetzt in der schinkenstraße in der
bierstraße passieren also so wie ich das
einschätzen
die leute die da runter kommen wollen
feiern dann gehen sie in die restaurants
fächern
da wird dann die musik bisschen lauter
gemacht darin stehen da die situation
wie sie jetzt in dem der wehrstraße
waren und da werden auch die restaurants
geschlossen werden weil es wird sich
verlagern
irgendwie wollen gefahren und in den
restaurants die sind auch dazu ausgelegt
die können auch der feier musikalisch
haben die alles da
ich weiß nicht ob sie umbauen werden
weil dafür haben sie zu wenig einnahmen
alle gehabt dieses jahr die jetzt war es
natürlich schön das war wieder offen so
langsam ich erinnere mich dass in dem
bei mama muh und da waren mittags nur
spanier dann kam die erste reisegruppe
aus deutschland die sind aufgestanden
die spanier haben applaudiert bauer die
deutschen kommen wieder damit kommt noch
das geld wieder
und da kommt jetzt noch mal wieder ein
schrank und die mallorca saison als
solches die panama sie sagen die läuft
ja immer ende september aus ich glaube
ich dass die dann noch mal irgendwas
machen anschließend ja das befürchten
wir auch ja vielen dank und kokos für
deine einschätzung
du kennst die szene da wirklich sehr gut
und danke dass du in dieser sendung
warst